imagine spending four years getting a university degree
taking on debt working internships
finally landing that entry level job
now imagine artificial intelligence doing that job better
faster and for a fraction of the cost
this is not a hypothetical
this is happening right now
Harvard Business School research published in 2026
revealed something that should alarm every parent in this room
after the launch of Chat GPT
job postings for structured repetitive work drops by 13%
and here is the part that surprises most people
these were not factory jobs
these were white collar jobs
office jobs
the kind of jobs we told our children to work hard in school to get
the old rules of career safety have changed completely
so let us talk honestly about what is disappearing
and what is being born
the jobs facing the steepest drop are the ones built almost entirely
on tasks that artificial intelligence can now do faster and cheaper
data entry clerks
artificial intelligence can automate roughly 95% of those tasks today
telemarketers and call center agents
artificial intelligence
now handles over 70% of routine customer inquiries
bookkeepers and basic accountants
The World Economic Forum lists them among the fastest declining roles
by 2030 administrative assistance and legal assistance
artificial intelligence platforms are already performing
contract reviews and legal research
translators and interpreters
Microsoft Research ranks this as the number one occupation
for artificial intelligence applicability
and entry level software developers
yes even coding
anthropic reports that 75% of basic
programming tasks are now highly exposed to artificial intelligence
automation
but here is the part of the story nobody is telling loudly enough
the entry level crisis is the most urgent problem facing young people
today
Goldman Sachs data shows that unemployment among 20 to 30 year olds
in technology exposed roles
has risen by roughly 3 percentage points since early 2025
IDC's 2026 report
found that 66% of enterprises are already reducing entry level hiring
as they deploy artificial intelligence
Gartner predicts that by the end of 2026
20% of organizations will use
artificial intelligence to eliminate
more than half of their current middle management positions
one former Fortune 500 chief executive described it this way
companies are burning the bottom rungs of the career ladder
to heat the house
the ladder our children expected to climb is being dismantled
while they are still in school
so what do we do with this information
we stop panicking and we start preparing
because the same technology that is closing those doors
is throwing open windows that lead to some of the most well paid
most meaningful most in demand careers in human history
here is what the job market actually looks like
for children who are prepared
artificial intelligent
and machine learning engineers earn an average of $206,000 per year
with projected job growth of 26% through 2033
prompt engineers a job title that did not exist three years ago
already command salaries from $63,000 to over $300,000 at top
artificial intelligence laboratories
with demand growing at 135% per year
artificial intelligence ethics officers
and responsible artificial intelligence specialists
earn between $90,000 and $180,000
forester predicts that 60% of Fortune 100 company will appoint
a dedicated head of artificial intelligence governance
by late 2026 artificial intelligence auditors
and compliance managers earn $130,000 to $200,000
and above
artificial intelligence safety
and alignment researchers
at leading laboratories are receiving total compensation packages
exceeding $1 million
data scientists are projected to see 34% employment growth
through 2034
The World Economic Forum lists big data specialist as the single
fastest growing role on the entire planet
and these are just the rules we can name today
almost 40% of chief executives report
that companies entered entirely new industries
because of artificial intelligence driven opportunities
the artificial intelligence governance industry alone
is projected to surpass $20 billion by 2026
new fields are forming right now around synthetic data
agenic artificial intelligence systems
and artificial intelligence powered healthcare diagnostics
however Professor Karim Lakani put it in a way
every parent and teacher needs to hear
artificial intelligence will not replace humans
but humans who use artificial intelligence
will replace humans who do not
The World Economic Forum projects that by 2030
47% of work tasks will still be performed primarily by humans
Another 30% will be collaborative
humans and artificial intelligence working together
Only 22% will be handled mainly by technology alone
in Episode 3 I will show you exactly what skills your child needs
to be irreplaceable in this new world
because it is not just about coding
it's something more powerful